bonjour vous aimez manger oui seulement
allongée ça tombe très bien parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va parler
d'alimentation médiévale bon on va
garder pour la fin tous les banques et
autres fait 5 que vous avez sûrement
déjà en tête parce qu'ils ne sont ni
représentative de toute la période
ni de tout le monde quand la prof parle
de période elle fait référence au haut
moyen âge le vème siècle à l'an mil au
moyen âge central du 11e au 13e siècle
et au bas moyen âge du 13e au xvème
siècle
et oui l'épisode d'aujourd'hui sera
chronologique est fantastique
évidemment on va s'intéresser à ce que
tous les différents groupes sociaux
avait dans mon assiette
et pour ça on va forcément par ses parts
de l'histoire de l'agriculture est aussi
par l'histoire des pratiques sociales
liées au repas est rallongé
ben non justement c'est un peu has been
[Musique]
à partir du 4e siècle des peuples
appelés les barbares arrive en europe
occidentale et sème la zizanie parmi les
habitudes alimentaires des romains par
la suite les habitants d'europe
occidentale opère un mélange entre les
avantages des romains et des barbares
comme on a assez peu de données
archéologiques pour cette période on se
base surtout sur des sources écrites
ce qui fait qu on sait assez peu de
choses sur les paysans mais surtout sur
le nord mais sur l'éclair parmi l'élite
romaine nous avions une alimentation
previn nous préférions le pain alors que
les paysans consommer leur serial en
bouillie nous pouvions manger des
légumes secs ouvert du fromage le vin
était toujours coupé d'eau et surtout
nous avions une sauce que nous mettions
absolument partout le gard où mme
c'était des entrailles de poisson
fermenté
nous avons gardé le plus longtemps
possible l'habitude de banque était sur
des ch'ti badoum ci sorte de lit de
table dans ce cas n'a fait qu'une pâle
copie
nous avions deux repas le prendre yum en
milieu de matinée et la cena en fin
d'après midi certains évêques du 6e
siècle maintenaient encore ces pratiques
mais les bonnes habitudes se sont vite
perdu effectivement l'arrivée de peuples
barbares a même bon nombre de pratiques
qui choque les romains attention ces
peuples n'avaient rien de sauvages
sanguinaire enfin presque il pratiquer
l'agriculture depuis bien longtemps et
savait très bien se tenir il n'avait
juste pas le même style
par exemple les boivent surtout de la
bière ou cervoise et ça choquait pas mal
les ecclésiastiques qui préférait le vin
pour eux la bière c'était la boisson des
adorateurs de dieu redonne odin pour les
intimes est donc un truc de païens il
consomme et leur viande grillée soi
disant que leur procurait force et
violence il goûtait très peu nos plats à
base de volailles et poissons
de plus ils accompagnaient leurs plats
d'oignons d'ail et surtout de beurre la
honte
ultime pour les romains ces pratiques
font d'ailleurs l'objet d'une lettre de
sidoine apollinaire qui se plaint de
l'odeur de la cuisine des burgondes qui
vivent chez lui et dont j'ai déjà parlé
dans l'épisode sur les digues burgondes
chez les barbares comme chez les romains
le repas est un rituel très important
régis par des codes dont on garde peu de
traces parce qu'on a assez peu de
sources écrites dans plusieurs récits de
banque et du haut moyen-âge
le récit de bérulle jeu par exemple la
reine présente au roi une poupe
d'hydromel devant ces guerriers ce qui
lui permet de réaffirmer son pouvoir en
anglais le mot lord est un dérivé
deux fois ford qui signifie le gardien
du pas en gros ont su mais que détient
les clés du lierre manger et qui voit en
premier par la suite les peuples
d'europe ce christianisme ce qui a des
conséquences sur leurs pratiques
alimentaires un calendrier du jeune se
met en place
ainsi que le péché de gourmandise qui
risque principalement les moines y la
règle de saint benoît par exemple écrite
au milieu du 6e siècle recommande les
légumes et le pain n'est interdit la
viande des quadrupèdes et n'autorise le
vin que de mauvaise qualité
elle interdit aussi la satiété et
l'ivresse chouette les banquets de
l'élite se plaît aussi aux règles de
l'église qui interdit qu'ils aient lieu
dans des églises à partir de 561 salé
s'est plaint de miettes à la fin à
partir de cette date les princes
construisent donc de grandes valembois
dédié aux banques et dont le but est
encore une fois d'impressionner les
invités mais alors que ray pye tombe en
ce début du moyen-âge puisque l'héritage
romain commence à disparaître les
aliments qui apportent le plus de
calories sont les serial et autres
légumineuses en europe c'est le blé qui
domine clairement avec ses potes
l'épeautre le sel de froment etc
en asie on trouve le riz en amérique
centrale le maïs bref chacun a sa
spécialité
on mange donc surtout du blé en points
ou en bouillie et quand ce n'est plus la
saison peut se rabattre sur d'autres
légumineuses comme les toits ou des
lentilles mais on n'aime pas trop ça
tout le reste du repas est considéré
comme de l'accompagnement qu'on appelle
et comme managing ce qui va avec le pain
il peut s'agir de légumes du jardin de
condiments de produits cueillis en forêt
comme les champignons de viande de
produits laitiers etc
parmi les viandes consommées on trouve
les poules ou canards oies boeufs
moutons chèvres et porcs à part le port
ils ont tous une utilité à côté on n'a
pas la place pour gaspillage pour ce qui
est des boissons on n'aime pas trop
l'eau à cette époque on préfère le vin
la boisson de l'époque
mais on peut aussi se rabattre sur de la
bière de l'hydromel ou d'autres boissons
alcoolisée à base de plantes par exemple
le dénominateur commun c'est l'alcool
quoi ouest et ancêtres et mais bien
quand ça monte au cerveau durant
l'époque carolingienne en garde ce
triptyque de la sainte bouffe serial 20
viande en quantité variable selon le
statut des gens dans certains documents
on trouve aussi mention d'arbres
fruitiers ou de jardin où on trouve à la
fois des plantes médicinales des
condiments
les légumes mais tout ça ça reste des à
côtés les banques et se faisait acier
plus allongée on y trouvait le repas la
colas you mais aussi la potasse you la
boisson présent commun au niveau de la
nourriture les récits de ces banques et
nous permettent de constater qu'à la fin
du haut moyen-âge
on n'utilise plus l'huile d'olive ni le
gars ont mérité des romains à la place
on voit apparaître de plus en plus des
pis le poivre la cannelle le galanga le
clou de girofle et surtout la star
incontestée du moyen-âge le gingembre à
partir du 11e siècle
le monde change on est toujours sur le
triangle serial 20 viande mais les
pécores de moins en moins de viande
les surfaces cultivées augmente plus
devient donc de plus en plus dépendant
des céréales et souffre parfois de
disette quand on a plus l'aliment
principal reste donc le pas et pour le
préparer des seniors ont une excellente
idée
les installe dans les villages des
moulins et des fours banaux à utiliser
obligatoirement et contre paiement bien
sûr quel genou au début du 11e siècle
les seniors vivent encore dans de petits
châteaux le plus souvent construit en
bois qu'on appelle lé château à motte y
avait pas vraiment la place pour
festoyer là dedans donc les halles
servant au festin était encore
construite à part on les appelait les à
houla puis rapidement ils deviennent des
châteaux forts dans lesquelles se trouve
la ola mais aussi des salles plus privé
où les seniors peut recevoir ces autres
vip pour griller en paix ils grillent un
peu tout puisque le champ par qui
prélèvent aux paysans lui permet d'avoir
du pain du vin du bourse des produits
laitiers
mais il mange surtout de la viande elle
est constituée à plus de 90% de viande
d'élevage le reste étant du gibier et de
la volaille les seigneurs chasser mais
il s'agissait surtout d'un loisir et
d'une manière de montrer qui était le
patron
donc il n'avait pas besoin de la chasse
pour vivre du côté des moines on
consomme surtout de la volaille mais
certains religieux comme bernard de
clairvaux s'inquiète de la montée de
pratiques peu catholiques de ces
derniers à partir du 12ème siècle
certains moines se mettent à cuisiner
des quadrupèdes alors que c'était
interdit à mettre des épices dans leur
vin pour qu'il est meilleur goût et même
à essayer d'assaisonner leurs plats pour
qu'ils aient meilleur goût aussi où les
l'a6 l'a10 cadence un an ville enfin on
trouve quelques jardins et vergers mais
la plupart des citadins sont des
flemmards et surtout n'ont pas de
cuisine chez eux donc les achats que
leur part déjà cuits leurs plats déjà
cuisinés ou vont à la taverne la vraie
vie on avance encore un peu dans le
temps à partir du 14e siècle on connaît
mieux les pratiques alimentaires grâce à
la plus grande diversité des sources
écrites mais aussi aux sources
iconographiques archéologiques etc
et en fait c'est un peu toujours la même
chose du pain du vin de la viande mais
tout ça coûte quand même cher pour les
seniors guillaume de murol un seigneur
auvergnat du 15e siècle consacre 50 4%
de son budget à l'achat de nourriture
alors qu'à l'époque moderne ça ne
représente que 5 à 20% du budget bouffe
les seigneurs et parmi ces aliments le
pas reste le plus important parce qu'on
peut s'en taper entre 500 g et 2 kg par
jour
par contre tout le monde n'a pas droit à
du pain béni chez les seniors où
commence par mangé son pain blanc
un pain à base de froment qui est
considérée comme la reine des céréales
c'est le phare du roi du coup forcément
ne trouve pas pour une bouchée de pain
ceux qui n'ont pas un gagne-pain
suffisants ne mange pas de ce pain là et
se contente de pain d'orge d'avoine le
tout ce qui pousse chez eux quoi gagnent
leur pain à la sueur de leur front
les nobles se retirerait vitse par là de
la bouche parfois quand les récoltes
sont mauvaises on fabrique même départ
de substitution à partir de tous
contrôles serial légumineuses même si ça
fait un peu dégueulasse
de quoi vous faire passer le goût du
pain pas de pain pas de gains il arrive
encore aussi comment je sais serial en
bouillie ou bien en pas tous en polenta
en italie pour ce qu'est la consommation
de viande aussi on observe des
différences entre nobles ep corps mais
pas que à propos saviez-vous qu'à mon
époque le mot viande désigner la
nourriture en général du coup le mot
viande on l'appeler la chair bref les
nobles et les membres de communauté que
ce soit des écoles des hôpitaux des
monastères étaient ceux qui s'empiffrent
et le plus logiquement mais il y avait
aussi de grosses différences entre les
villes où on mange jusqu'à 20 kg de
viande par an et les campagnes où ce
chiffre peut descendre à 2 kg par an ça
s'explique par le fait qu'il y a plus de
boucherie en ville et ça explique aussi
le fait que la viande en ville est
plutôt consommée fraîche alors que dans
les campagnes en attendant salle à
manger salé ou séchées pour qu elles se
conservent plus longtemps dans les
villes
il y a d'ailleurs une spécialisation de
plus en plus importante dans les métiers
d'alimentation on trouve des boulangers
les charcutiers est à vernier qui
doivent obéir à des règles de métier
précise par exemple les bouchers ont
interdiction de vendre de la viande
cuite
parce que c'est la spécialité des
charcutiers d'ailleurs on ne faisait pas
qu acheter de la nourriture chez ses
artisans
mais on pouvait aussi y faire cuire ses
propres plats parce que comme on l'a
déjà dit plutôt très peu d'urbain avait
chez eux une cuisine où il se miner
après même si on consommer de la viande
de préférence très cuite il y avait plus
d'une centaine de jours de jeunes dans
l'année les jours où la consommation de
viande était interdite pendant carême on
interdit aussi la consommation d'oeufs
et de produits laitiers et certains
moines vont jusqu à respecter les jeunes
du mercredi du samedi et de l'avant
ça fait beaucoup de jour sans viande ou
on la remplace par du poisson durant ces
moments même les graisses animales sont
remplacés par de l'huile d'olive ou du
lait d'amande
on consomme surtout des poissons d'eau
douce pour des soucis évidents
d'approvisionnement les poissons d'eau
de mer peuvent être apportées dans les
grandes villes par des convois de 50 à
200 chevaux
on appelle cette organisation
chasse-marée on peut aussi les manger de
conserve ou salés à partir du 14e siècle
par exemple le hareng devient un poisson
super répandue parce qu'on peut
facilement le conserver jusque carrément
la graisse de baleine quant à elle n'est
jamais interdites y considère la baleine
comme un poisson au niveau des boissons
ont fait pousser de la vigne presque
partout en europe et on consomme environ
un litre de vin par repas soit 2 litres
par jour
mais il dépasse rarement les 10 degrés
d'alcool quand même on n'avait pas trop
boire de l'eau pas pour les microbes on
savait même pas ce que c'était mais
parce que la vo 15 malheureusement
durant certaines périodes de disette le
vin devient trop cher pour les pauvres
pécore doivent alors se rabattre sur
d'autres boissons comme le cidre par
exemple où la bière comme elle en corse
cervoise où elle en angleterre donc lui
il ya deux brasseries dans une ville
plus on comprend qu'il ya un problème
d'approvisionnement va finalement la
bière se popularise en europe du nord et
on généralise l'utilisation du houblon
dans sa fabrication à partir du 14e
siècle ce qui se développe de plus en
plus enfin sont les épices du 14e au
16ème siècle c'est l'apogée des éclisses
en europe on les fait venir grâce aux
commerçants vénitiens ou génois d'inde
de chine d'indonésie
parce qu'elle donne un bon gros os plein
et viennent d'orient dont touche à
l'imaginaire des européens qui se font
encore unités légèrement biaisée de
lorient y'a qu'a voir ma vidéo sur marco
polo s'en rendre compte
et pour vous donner un autre exemple on
pensait que la cannelle et est cueilli
dans le nid du phénix ce qui est peu
probable
le gingembre et les pis la plus présente
mais on trouve aussi la cannelle
le safran le galanga la bonne muscade et
quelques épices européennes comme la
moutarde laye où la sauge au moyen âge
on se moquait pas mal du goût d'un
aliment tout seul ce qui intéressait les
cuistots c'était les mélanges hydaelyn
en dépis auprès des saveurs nouvelles
évidemment c'est dans la noblesse qu'on
en consomme le plus à partir du 15e
siècle de nouvelles routes commerciales
permettent de faire un peu baisser les
prix la boisson la plus représentative
de ce bout pour les épices et l'hypocras
un mélange d'une petite dizaine des
pistes concerts surtout en fin de repas
avec des gaufres tous les aliments cités
jusqu'ici font l'objet de livres de
cuisine qui apparaissent à partir de la
fin du xiiie siècle comme le viandier
qui est très diffusé et propose de
nombreuses recettes
on trouve aussi à partir du xvième
siècle des manuels de civilité qui
explique comment bien se tenir à table
où sont les poulains ya pas quels que
soient son avec de la bonne foi et on va
terminer sur la table justement en
s'attaquant enfin aux banquets médiévaux
ont déjà y'a pas de table des autres
vous saviez peut-être déjà mais il ya
très peu de meubles fixe dans les
châteaux à cette époque parce que la
cour est encore souvent itinérante du
coup on pose des tréteaux avec des
planches dessus et voilà pour la table
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne soigne pas
ses invités on met deux belles tentures
sur les murs souvent en couleurs des
invités ou de l'hôte de la vaisselle
d'or et d'argent pour les invités les
plus prestigieux au sol on répond une
jonque chez de foin et de fleurs et on
pose différents objets décoratifs et
utiles sur la table les objets réservé
aux invités des plus prestigieux sont
les nefs sont de grands plats en forme
de navire dans lesquelles les invités
peuvent déposer leurs couverts leur
reste et c'est on met des nappes
blanches aussi sa cache les très tôt et
on peut s'essuyer les 26 par contre on
ne mettait pas le couvert comme
aujourd'hui on a porté le tout avec les
pleins la nourriture était dans des
écuelles si elle était liquide ou posés
sur des tranches de pain appelé
tranchoir qui finissait ensuite dans la
gueule des chiens y avait aussi du vrai
beau pain blanc destinés à être mangés
il pouvait y avoir des couteaux et des
cuillères mais pas de fourchette avant
le 16e siècle est de toute façon manger
plutôt avec les doigts les invités
d'honneur occuper la table du au bout
d'os à l'acheminer par opposition à
celle d'ubs à bout pour les inviter les
moins prestigieux à qui on disait donc
babou babou avant de commencer à manger
on se lave les mains comme on va mettre
ses mains dans le plat ensuite commencer
pas vous emballez sur l'hygiène de
pourquoi se laver les mains ça veut
surtout dire se lécher les doigts avant
de les mettre dans le plat chacun ses
valeurs pour ce qui est du repas les
banques et sont divisés en différents
mais dans lesquels on trouve des plats
chauds froids sucré salé poisson ou
viande
il ya beaucoup de place durant ces
banquiers mais ils sont destinés à être
répartis sur les différentes tables donc
les invités ne mange pas de tout
comportement pour leur estomac
on commence souvent par les potages puis
l'euro non celle rôti il peut aussi
s'agir de tours tous deux pattes et vers
la fin du moyen-âge
alors que les aliments cuits ont été
très largement favorisé tout autant de
cette époque il peut arriver concernent
des plats de salade aux invités le plus
prestigieux
vers la fin du repas on sert de
l'hypocras avec des gaufres puis le
dernier bleu dont j'adore le nom le
bouton or qui indique aux invités qu'il
est bientôt temps de dégager
pratique pour abréger les repas de
famille il est constitué d'un digestif
accompagné de quelques sucreries comme
du gingembre confit
mais le banquet a surtout une fonction
sociale et politique on veut en mettre
plein la vue
ça passe par l'assiette mais pas
seulement dû rentrer plusieurs heures et
plusieurs jours comme lors des noces de
charles le téméraire où on festoie dix
jours en plus les restes des banques et
sont distribués comme aumône donc on
peut même passer pour généreux le
caractère grandiloquent de ces banques
et s'observent grâce aux entre eux mais
sont de petits spectacles dans des
décors de carton peint ou d'aliments
montré entre les plans
[Musique]
il peut aussi s'agir d'aliments mise en
scène comme un signe cuit puis à nouveau
recouverts de ses plumes certains
banques et du 15e siècle sont mémorables
le banquet des noces de charles le
téméraire déjà le duc prend son repas
seul le premier soir alors que tout le
monde fait la fête à côté parce qu'il
n'est pas encore mariée avec sa future
femme
alors il faudrait pas trop heurter les
moeurs l'entremet de ce banquet était
constitué de deux chandeliers
monumentaux ornés de miroirs avec des
roches et des montagnes à leurs pieds
pourquoi il profite aussi de ce banquet
pour offrir un spectacle au peuple de
bruges et tous les restes du festin
quand 1466 le pape paul ii organise lui
aussi un banquet mais il ne fait pas les
choses à moitié
il s'agit d'un manque est destiné à
toute la population de rome donc une
sorte de goûter monumental servi dans
les jardins du palais sa marque pour les
pâtes servi à ce banquet il a fallu
acheter lui 1571 3112 parmesan et il y
avait plus de 900 invités j'ai dépensé
sont enfin l'un des banquets médiévaux
les plus célèbres et le banquet du
faisan organisé à lille par le duc de
bourgogne philippe lebon en 1454 il a
lieu à l'occasion de la visite des ducs
de clèves et d'alençon et sert aussi au
projet politique du duc puisqu'il se
clôt par la promesse des invités à
partir en croisade bon mais finalement
une fois la digestion passé chacun est
rentré chez soi mais c'était une sacrée
digestion le banquet dure plusieurs
jours avec des successions de tournois
et de repas le plus important ayant lieu
le 17 février à l'entrée du banquet on
trouve un d'entre eux mais dans lequel
une statut d'enfant tout nu piste de
l'eau rose appétissant l'autre entre eux
mais célèbre met en scène en faisant
vivant sur lequel les invités prêtent
leur serment de croisade
les descriptions de ces banques et
montre vraiment tout ce qui faisait
l'époque féodale et chevaleresque on a
un seigneur entouré de ses vassaux qui
respectent le code chevaleresque en
organisant des tournois et d entre eux
mais qui montre aussi sa puissance
et pourtant les banques n était pas
réservé aux nobles bien au contraire
chez les pécores ont festoyé lors de
grandes fêtes religieuses pour les
baptêmes les mariages les enterrements
et on ne faisait pas gaffe à la dépense
il y avait du pain blanc du vin de la
viande salée ou fraîches
on pouvait même tuer les animaux de
travail s'il le fallait bon après on
était bien embêté quand il fallait tirer
soi-même sa chambre pour terminer
l'alimentation médiévale a évolué en
termes de goût
de proportion mais elle garde très
longtemps cette répartition des serial
du pain et de la viande
le reste constituant des accompagnements
puisque les serial était la principale
source de calories
depuis l'industrialisation et surtout
20e siècle on est sortis de cette
organisation
mais on la retrouve encore dans d'autres
pays par exemple en asie du sud est où
la serial principal et lloris qui
constituent encore l'essentiel de
l'alimentation et tout ce qui se mange à
côté sert à l'accompagner et à lui
donner du goût alors j'espère que cet
épisode vous a plu et vous a mis en
appétit
pour ma part je vais vous laisser c'est
l'heure du goûter quand je vois tu vin
clairet amis tout tourne autour de tours
de tourner aussi désormais je bois anjou
a beau quand je bois du vin clairet amis
tout tourne autour de tourner autour d'
aussi désormais je bois bonjour beau
chanteur ou un sac ou faisant la guerre
chants danses et mes amis eu bon dos
j'entends ces mouvements à sanaa qu'en
faisant la guerre
j'entends c'est devant mes amis du bon
bien à l'abandon à ça qu'on fait dans la
guerre vivant bien à bord dont un seul
flacon faisant la guerre
jambon ce flacon faisant la guerre ce
flacon faisons la guerre quand je vois
tu vas créer mais tout on attend
maintenant de tourner aussi désormais je
bois arrange ou à bois quand je vois du
vin clairet à mes tomates en attendant
tourne aussi désormais je bois en jouant
chantant et buvant mois sa femme en
faisant la guerre
chantant ses maisons mes amis me vantant
champion s'est tu vois ça flacon faisant
la guerre chanteuse émouvant mes amis du
bon temps